sakai
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui de quoi on parle
regarder derrière moi c'est une voie
dédiée ici là ça c'est des trottinettes
électriques trottinette électrique made
in france la masse et tek tek tek et
vous allez voir ce envoie du bois
[Musique]
c'est là tu es pro de ce deuxième modèle
de texte etc take away
donc nous sommes des concepteurs
français les ingénieurs français
'cela fait là le tout nouveau modèle
alors ça c'est le tout nouveau modèle
qui est sorti à peine un mois et qu'ils
aient eu la chance de tester ma mère
j'espère que ça t'a plu mais quand même
on était un peu sous la pluie on est
passé sur nous mais ça s'est bien passé
mis neige c'est un produit pour adultes
un qui puisse porter une charge de 100
kg qu'un système de freinage complexe
progressif freins à disques se fera un
disque sur le sur la roue arrière sur la
roue arrière parce que c'est une
propulsion est donc tous les efforts se
font au niveau de la roue arrière ou
arrière plein
increvable et également frein magnétique
avec récupération d'énergie jeu se passe
a remarqué quand on l'utilisé la barre
d'énergie est descendu et à les remonter
au bout d'un certain moment grâce à la
récupération d'énergie et là par rapport
à ceinturer qu parle pas beaucoup tu
récupères un petit peu mais ils sont par
rapport à une charge complète ça
représente quoi
alors c'est évidemment c'est pas
éternelle où tu récupères quelques pour
cent mais on est quand même bien
agréable de voir ça ça chambre pas plus
que 15 jours au niveau du confort tu as
pu remarquer que m'ont même sur les
pavés sa place est relativement bien ça
c'est dû au diamètre des roues très qui
est très supérieur à la moyenne du
marché
nathan est aussi à la largeur il ya
beaucoup d'adhérence grâce à cette
largeur de pneus et donc on a vu une
très grosse puissance pour pouvoir
compenser les frottements et pneus avant
la chambre à air donc gonflables ou quoi
en matière de confort la plaque aussi
ici qu'on a développés qui amortit les
secoue qui amortit les chocs et tout ça
dans l'optique d'avoir une sensation de
confort et de sécurité
on est passés entre des bus un petit peu
un peu un peu piétons mais tu avais
quand même ce sentiment de sécurité
complètement la trottinette est allumée
signalisation arrière quand tu freines
un tel indicateur également le cadre est
en alu de très bonne qualité très épais
pour une durabilité maximale à ça a été
testé par des professionnels de bmx
ok donc qui ont fait des figures dans
tous les sens pour pousser le produit
assez limité pour être sûr qu'on est un
truc absolument fiable alors
l'accélération elle se fait avec la
[ __ ] en balle exactement
l'accélération se fait au pied comme sur
une voiture parce que ça nous semblait
plus instinctif d'augmenter vu la prise
en main se fait en deux minutes quand tu
as compris j'en trouvais l'équilbre ça
ça passe très bien
et puis surtout le fait d'avoir
l'accélération au pied ça libère les
mains pour le directionnel est pour et
pour le freinage donc vraiment axé
sécurité une fois de plus et d une
petite béquille latérale la pologne en
moi nous sommes constructeurs et donc
avec nous vous avez accès à toutes les
pièces de rechange et vous êtes pris
surtout en charge directement par le
constructeur vous n'avez pas à passer
par quelqu'un qui s'y connaît pas si
vous nous appelez si vous envoyez un
mail vous tombez directement sur un
ingénieur qui a conçu le produit au du
garanti
en 30 jours satisfait ou remboursé pour
vous assurer que le produit correspond
bien l'utilisation que vous souhaitez en
faire et garanties techniques de deux
ans à charge totale c'est 100 kg voilà
c'est ça ouais en solo alors à 2 50 kg
avec enseigne actuellement c'est de
faire rire c'est possible indiquait
alors l'autonomie l'autonomie de 25 km 5
km tu préfère quand même avec 25 km
voilà exactement surtout que c'est un
véhicule d'appoint donc souvent l'emmène
au bureau on a le temps de recharger au
bureau odeur de rentrer chez soi vitesse
de pointe à 25 km heure tu m'as dit 25
km/heure web le plat ça va rendre un tas
de quoi faire il la plupart des
trottinettes sur le marché demande à ce
que on est une inertie
à la base c'est à dire lancé la
trottinette jeu coude voilà alors
celle-ci il suffit d'appuyer sur
l'accélérateur et la trottinette démarre
immédiatement le moins cahoteux donc tu
te mets à l'art et appuyez dessus
elle se lance voilà comme une voiture un
véhicule trop j'ai ressenti de l'adn de
la boîte quand tu me la présentez tu
m'expliquer te dis voilà moi je prends
les gens au téléphone ce qui vous avez
d'autres produits aussi je les prends au
téléphone fait de trouver les solutions
trouver la solution pour vraiment
satisfait est un client c'est vraiment
le le plus que vous avez vous par
rapport à d'autres marques concurrentes
alors on est une marque française avec
bright road qui est développée pour le
marché français
quand vous nous contactez vous tombez
sur des ingénieurs concepteurs du
produit
ok donc ils vont pas vous diriger vers
un service en particulier qui vont
prendre directement en charge et qui
vous sont capables de vous accompagner
si vous êtes un problème de livraison de
votre produit mais également un problème
technique quel qu'il soit et c'est
résolu dans la journée jusqu'à atteindre
votre satisfaction totale on ne laisse
aucun client qui n'est pas satisfait
quelle que soit la raison que vous a
souvent ralentis ou pas qu'il est au
bord de la route
on est là bon ok cool
bon écoute je te remercie je vous mets
le lien en bas dans la description si
vous voulez aller voir ce produit tu me
disais qu'en termes de coût il allait au
combat à l'autre elle est à 599 alors on
peut proposer ce prix souvent les
trottinettes qui ont une qualité
similaire avec une puissance similaire
moins de 350 watts du nominal sont
plutôt aux alentours de mi
200 euros coll là on est à 599 grâce à
notre politique de vente directe donc la
vente directe c'est quoi on s'était
c'est à dire qu'on court circuite tous
les intermédiaires historiques que sont
les magasins les distributeurs les
grossistes d'accord et moi qui demandent
des marges assez importante des fois de
50%
on n'est pas obligé de s'aligner sur
leurs prix pour ne pas leur faire
concurrence on ne vend qu'en direct
d'accord donc vous n'avez aucune image
cool bon bah écoute bravo continuation
mais cette quantité de vous intéresse je
vous ai tous mis en bas dans la
description et dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous sur l'a30 et électrique est
ce que vous utilisez une faute et
électriques
est ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser
on voit que ça se développe beaucoup la
législation se développe énormément faut
donner un cadre légal parce que comme il
ya un vrai boulet un grand succès pour
la trottinette nous forcément un cadre
légal donc pour la trottinette on va
continuer à en parler on va en tester
plein en tout cas celle là je la trouve
vraiment cool très cool le fait d'avoir
la l'accélération la [ __ ] sa masse est
plutôt agréable ces gros peu donnent des
sensations
c'est vrai qu'une vraiment agréable là
sur les pavés à paris vous cache pas que
ça secoue un peu et du coup on censé
rassurer donc ça c'est ça c'est un point
positif donc vous ne marquez tout ça en
commentaire vous dites ce que vous en
pensez vous avez bien évidemment à vous
abonner puis je vous dis tout net on va
en parler vous ne marquez tout ça à très
bientôt merci à toi merci à serge milhas
continuation merci bien
ciao au revoir
non